so uh welcome everyone to the the third
course
of the third lecture in the course on
pcp theorems we're happy to have back to
tell us about parallel repetition
okay so thanks um yeah
so uh thanks for coming again hopefully
today the
internet will on my side be a bit better
um so i apologize for last time so
in the past two lectures we gave a
introduction on pcps and donna
gave a very nice lecture about proving
the
a weak pcp theorem today and
in the last lecture on monday our goal
is to talk about
more advanced topics in a more survey
like
fashion and kind of describe connections
to high dimensional geometry which
as far as or at least the kind of
geometry that we
think that maybe will interest the
workshop by participants
it's it's always hard to predict what
other people care about
anyway so what is parallel repetition
and how is it related to what we talked
about before
so let's remember
the basic pcp theorem which basically
said
if you have a graph in the language of
three coloring
it is empty hard to decide if a given
graph
in
slam if if a given graph has
a perfect three coloring meaning you can
color the vertices so that all the edges
are happy
or every three falsifies at least one
percent
of the edges so it has value 0.99 and
every 999
so that's what we call the basic pcp
theorem and i happen to describe it in
the language of three coloring
and then dana showed how you can also
describe it in the language of quadratic
equations
and there are many other constraints
satisfaction problems
that you can cast this into and a couple
that we talked about were
three oops three in which
is when you have linear equations
mode two and each equation
each equation has three variables
and i i quoted the theorem of hashtag
which says it's empty hard
to tell if the value of a given trillion
instance so
let me denote it by equations
this is just an instance
plus three in if the value is
large it's almost one or if the value
of the same instance is at most half
plus epsilon and we said that this is
tight
okay so unlike the situation here
where uh 0.99 versus one is not
necessarily tight it's just
already making us happy because there's
a constant yeah
here the parameters are actually tight
in the sense that
you cannot expect a larger gap in linear
equations because there's an algorithm
that shows that actually
telling between a larger gap is not in
not np hard it's actually in polynomial
time
so this is tight of course assuming p is
not equal to 20.
this is for three names and has it also
showed that
it's np hard given a three set
given a three set instance
let me call it i don't know psi so
preset instance is
you know you have boolean variables and
you have clauses of the form
x1 or x2 or not x3
x1 or x5 or 7
and so on this is a 3 set and here you
prove
that the value it's and be hard to
decide if the value of this instance
is 1 meaning there is actually a
satisfying assignment
or if the value is less than 0.99
no actually 0.99 is not very interesting
because this is the same kind of
behavior we had here
there's nothing special about the number
0.99 so what is the number that i should
write here
that's actually tight this is 7 8 plus
epsilon
and the reason for 7 8 is that again
there's a very simple polynomial time
algorithm
that finds an assignment that satisfies
7 8 of the
clauses and what this theorem is telling
us actually you cannot do any better
okay so uh just again to say what is
value here the the this uh
notation is different depending on the
problem when i talk about three sets the
value is the fraction of clauses when i
talk about
three line the value is the fraction of
equations and when you talk about three
coloring it's the fraction of
edges it's always the fraction of
constraints
okay so how how do you prove such a
theorem of hasta then
how general is it i mean are the three
sat
and three lean problems that i'm showing
here let me highlight this
so i have here three sat and i have your
three lean
and is it actually is this theorem does
it generalize to every possible csp
so first first of all let me just say
that
when this came out it was incredibly
shocking
that even one can prove such a tight era
but
no you cannot continue and prove it for
every csp
for this this is still open but
it does follow from something called the
unique games conjecture
so this will be discussed i think mostly
on
monday but we will return to this today
as well
so um let's talk about how hasta
proved his result and the way he did it
was by moving to
one a csp called label cover
and this is uh just a specific
constraint satisfaction problem just
like you have three line and three sat
you also have label cover and then using
parallel repetition
which i denote by this tensor
product d because parallel repetition is
a term that
it's a kind of tensorization of the
instance it's a kind of direct product
of the instance
you will get into a another label cover
instance but this time
let me call it strong level cover
so really what's going on here i also
write the word parallel repetition
there's a transformation from a csp with
some
gap that is more of the form here which
is just a gap between
one and something slightly less than one
and you you get a transformation
into a gap that's between one and zero
or more correctly between one and almost
zero one and epsilon which is the
largest possible gap you can
have and once you have such a very
strong apcp
and so this way sometimes called the
strong
pcp theorem
once you have such a strong pcp you can
apply all kinds of
local encodings like gadgets and get
these very strong results
past that and many more this is already
going to be described next week
okay so let me move to uh
to uh
talk about color repetition and label
color
so what is label curve let's define
level power
the level cover instance
is given it's given by a bipartite graph
i should do it instance instance
is given by a bipartite graph
g whose vertices are a b and
edges e okay so i have here
where this is a i have vertices
b and i have edges
okay let's say this is u and this is b
and there's also a parameter so level
cover with parameter
a r okay
parameter r says what is the size of the
label shape so you should think of r as
some
constant parameter but it's kind of
arbitrarily large it's like the alphabet
size
so the the vertices here are going to be
like variables
of a constraints a destruction problem
and they get values in some
we call them labels here but it's not
like zero or one or maybe a color in one
two three it can be a number
in an alphabet of size r okay so there's
two label sets
and now describing what the label cover
instance is so there's two label sets
l a and l b these are label sets
whose size is at most r
so that's how the parameter comes in
and for every edge for every edge
you also have a function fuv
there is a function
if you v from the label set a to
the labels of b so actually what i'm
describing
here is called the projection game level
curve there's a projection from the
levels on the a side to the b
side so i'm just i'm going to call it
label cover for here
and so the label cover instance is given
not only by the graph
but also by for every edge you need to
give me this little function from l a to
l b
okay now we define the value
of a labeling so now
how is this a constraint satisfaction
problem someone needs to come and label
the vertices
so labeling is some assignment from the
vertex sets
to the label sets labels and
vertices in a should get labels in l a
and so on
vertices in b labels in a b and the
value of this labeling sigma
is is is defined to be the fraction
of edges that satisfy this
function so what does it mean to satisfy
the function if i label this vertex by
some
label alpha and i label this vertex by
some label beta
it needs to be that f of this edge
of alpha should equal beta this means
this is this means that the edge u v
is satisfied
okay so this is the constraint on every
edge fuvery specifies a constraint for
me
and the value of the entire labeling of
the entire graph
is just the probability over all
edges in the graph that fuv
of sigma of u
equals sigma of v
okay so the probability that this
overall edges i could have written
instead of this kind of heavy
notation i could have just written that
this edge is satisfied
uv is happy
okay so the probability that this edge
is happy this is exactly
defined as the value of sigma
with respect of course to this instance
and the value of the level cover is the
maximum if you go over all possible
assignment sigma
you want the labeling that is the best
this is the value of your own recovery
okay so now it's very easy so this is a
simple claim
to see that the basic
pcp theorem
implies that uh and it's np hard
to decide
uh on a gap of in
one mind or actually i don't know
get me right i don't know 0.999 and
one label cover
and this notation we didn't have it
before
oops okay label cover
this notation gap and two numbers
it's it's shorthand for having to write
it can be hard to decide if the value is
one or if the value is less than 0.99
okay so it's just notation you have a
gap between these two values
why is this uh this uh as
as you've seen already in the last
previous lectures
uh there are many different csps and
it's kind of easy to move between them
sometimes this moving between them or
doing a reduction
is not so evident for example when you
move from three coloring to quadratic
equations
we say it's easy but really you need to
understand how to do the reduction
here it's actually really easy you if
you know for example
that the graph recoloring is uh np hard
with a gap
you construct the label cover instance
by putting a vertex on the a
side for every edge and a vertex on the
b
side for every vertex in your graph that
you're trying to three color
and the labels on the edges should tell
you a coloring of both end points of the
edges
and the labels on the vertices should
tell you are coloring just of the vertex
of course the labels on the a side
should only allow
legal colorings so you only have three
times two
possible levels for every edge because
their colors should be different
and the font the fuv will just
check consistency if if the edge on the
a side is between some vertex v1 and v2
then you want that the label on this
edge is consistent with the label on the
other side uh so it's it's just a very
simple transformation and it shows you
that this
gap level covers in behind very very
easily
okay
not only that if you notice in my in the
way i described it
in the label set in the level cover that
i constructed was small
it was size six size six for the big
player in size three for the smart game
okay now uh we already had this in the
first
lecture so sometimes you can describe
something in a very
kind of csp or kind of static way but
there's also a
more personified dramatized view and
this is the
uh the two player game
so let me call this the dramatized
perspective on
level cover which is a
two player one round game
so what is the story here let's look at
this picture i like
to describe this when i look at the
picture of the graph okay so
i have this in mind this graph
and there are two players one is called
alice the other is called bob
there is a referee and
the referee selects an edge in this
graph at random
and then the referee sends the one end
point u
is sends to alice and one endpoint v
descends to bob so alice only knows you
she doesn't know which which edge which
v
and bob only knows v the alice needs to
respond with some kind of answer which
is a label
in l.a and bob needs to also respond
with some kind of answer which is
a labeling ld and then the referee looks
at these two answers alpha and beta
and makes some computations which amount
to
ask computing whether f of u v computed
on alpha equals beta
and the referee says yes or no and
in this game the value of the game is
the probability that the referee says
yes
the probability that the players win the
game okay so this is called
the winning probability of the game and
uh you can see that it's exactly the
value of the label color
okay it's just describing this whole
situation
uh as a as a game okay
and notice that indeed
the value of the game is the same as the
value of the level cover because
from the point of view of a and b
alice only gets in one round of the game
which is
we're only running for one round alice
just gets
a quer a question which is one vertex
and she needs to answer with some level
so to describe what alice is doing to
describe her strategy all you need to
tell me is for every vertex
what label alice is giving so a labeling
of alice's vertices
is a strategy for items and similarly
for bob
okay so the success probability
is the value of the level cards the same
thing
okay so to summarize what i said we have
players
a and b and b referee
free selects a
edge uv at random
sense to alice in
v21
a replies with alpha
but b replies with beta and the referee
accepts this is one round because
they're for recent something and the
players answers and the game is over
and they're very accepted and only if
fuv of alpha
equals
all right so so far we just described
what a two-player game is
and now we're ready to describe the
parallel repetition
okay so it's very actually much more
convenient to describe parallel
repetition when you talk
in this saying personified the way so
what is the parallel repetition
repetition what uh the referee
runs d different games
in parallel so what does that mean
[Music]
the referee selects
not one edge but the
edges u1 v1 u2
v2 and so on ud vd
okay independently
in in the edge set
okay and after therefore he selects
these edges it sends
the first endpoints u1 up to ud to alice
and let me call it alice not a and
v1 up to vd to bob
and alice and bob look at their
uh the information that they got the
questions and then alice responds
alice sends alpha one up to alpha d
bob sends better one up to better d
so it's a d tuple of levels
and the referee accepts
if if what
if for every i f of u i
v i of alpha equals beta i
if they're right on every single
coordinate okay
i is one to be
okay so that's the parallel repetition
game as you describe it
in a is again the reason it's called
parallel repetition
is to distinguish it from sequential
repetition
uh when people think about different
kinds of interactions and rounds then
it's very natural to say
first i send their first sends an edge
and then the players respond and then
the referee sends another edge and then
they respond again this would be two
rounds
and if you do it sequentially the rounds
it's a different type of
object than this object where it's still
one round
there they're free select something
sense to the players
the players respond and that's it so
it's still the same type of object as we
had before
it just relates differently to the label
cover instance
and really what's going on here is what
what do we have here
we really have a different type of level
just a different level cover instance
we're really working not with the
initial
level cover graph but with a tensorized
version of it
where um
where the new a it's really a
to the d here the vertices correspond
to tuples u1 up to ud
of elements in a and the new being is b
to the d
the vertices correspond to tuples in b
right these are the questions that alice
can get
you want up to ud and these are the
questions that bob can get if you want
the label set is also l a
to the power d and lb to the power d
so i i guess i shouldn't here i
shouldn't use tensor product
it's just it's just the product
l b to the d
and the functions i'm not going to write
it but
we understand what the function is it's
the function exactly that describes
this this behavior of the referee
you're checking a label a labeling
alpha one up to alpha d matches with
beta one up to beta d
if they match in every single form okay
so we basically
took a label cover instance and we
tensorized it in a bipartite way
and we got a new label cover instance so
by the way if you think of just the
underlying graph of
of the label cover remember a label
cover is a graph plus these constraints
so if you just think of the graph and
you write the adjacency matrix
of the bipartite graph so you have a
here and b here
and you tensorize this matrix with
itself d
times you will get the adjacency matrix
of this graph
so that's why it's really a
tensorization it's just a
bipartite personalization but
okay so now it's very natural to ask
okay what happens to the value of the
game
okay so question
uh oops
[Music]
okay question what happens
to the value of
let's call it g to the d compared to the
value of g
okay so if the value of g
was one suppose to the initial game the
players had a perfect winning strategy
then clearly also now they have a
perfect winning strategy they should
just answer
in a way this is perfectly consistent
with the previous uh strategy in every
coordinate
okay if valve g is one then
val g to the d is one
this should be clear i'm sorry my check
marks are reversed because i'm
left-handed
okay this is one thing what happens if
the value of g
is smaller than one i don't know it's
maybe one minus epsilon
then uh well i can still have the
players
answer each coordinate independently
and then they will have a value of one
minus epsilon to the d
okay because with probability one minus
epsilon
the the referee chooses d
the edges so the first edge with
probability one minus epsilon is
actually a good one
the second edge again with probability
one minus epsilon seven one
where they actually know how to succeed
so if they answer in a
product strategy the probability of
success is one minus absolutely
so i can definitely write this now it's
very tempting to actually write equality
and
in initially when these games were
studied people mistakenly wrote that
um but there's no reason to
expect that the players always play a
product strategy the players can
actually maybe
play a different kind of strategy okay
and so
uh it could be that the value is
actually much higher than one minus
epsilon integrity
okay and this was the parallel
repetition question can you prove
that as d goes to infinity as you repeat
the game more and more
that at least the value goes to zero
okay and this was shown
at first it was shown that it goes to
zero at samurai then it was shown to go
to zero
trade polynomial in d by five again
killian and then run russ proved
the famous parallel repetition theorem
this was in
95 uh
it shows that the value of g
to the d uh goes down
one minus epsilon to some power
i guess maybe it was 32 i don't know and
to the d
so you should read if the initial value
was one minus epsilon
then as you repeat the value goes to
zero and it goes to zero
exponentially fast okay
so that was a big achievement
and
it gives us what we need because as we
said
the graph g to the d or or this
operation of
parallel repetition of the game is
giving us a new label cover
and if initially we had a gap between
1.99
then as we take d to be larger and
larger our gap would be between
1 and 0.999 to the power
of d i moved from 0.99 to 0.999
to kind of take into account this 32
okay so but but of course you take d to
be as large as you need and
of course this value will go to zero in
the no case and
remain at one in the yes case and you
have a gap a very strong gap repair
for parallel repetition so the corollary
of this
is that the level cover
with gap in
epsilon versus one is np hard
and remember i told you that level
coverage comes with a parameter which is
the alphabet size
the alphabet it needs only to be
polynomial
in one minus in one over epsilon so it's
a constant it depends on epsilon as it
should
and it's only pulling one so that's
sometimes important
okay
so i told you that initially people
until kind of things started to fall
into place it was not clear whether
the value of the parallel petition is
perfectly decreasing exponentially and
then
all kinds of strange counter examples
were found where
you have a game whose value is something
like three quarters
and then you repeat it twice and the
value remains three quarters
it doesn't even decrease at all so all
kinds of weird behavior
happens but
slowly things became more understood and
i i'm not going to describe to you now a
counter example
like that instead we will soon see
the geometric interpretation of
of this value and when we talk about
that you will see
a geometric example of how the value
doesn't have to go down
as fast as it does in the product
strategy
as i said whereas proved that it does go
down exponentially fast but the question
is
in this case how fast okay
uh before that i just want to say that
people have
worked on trying to understand the proof
and get
maybe better parameters for example this
exponent of 32 and
uh there were many words in this and
eventually hollenstein and rao showed
that for this kind of games for
projection games
the theorem can be improved so that
instead of 32 you can have two so we
know that the value
of g to the d is less than one minus
epsilon squared to the d okay
this is for projection games
all the games we talk about today are
projection games so
doesn't matter in particular unique
games are projection games and fun
okay at this point um
in order to prove for example hashtags
results this is not
important at all but
uh now i'm going to take a detour and
discuss a little bit uh
unique games and max path because uh
this direction of research actually
started to care very much about the
about this constant too okay
so as i told you before let me scroll
up a little bit as i told you before
here when we talked about the
3sat and 3d huston managed to prove
tight results for a number of
very centrally constrained satisfaction
problems
but not all of them and for example one
very
basic uh constraints attracting problem
is
the problem of max cut what is max cut
max cut is like recoloring
except not three colors with two colors
you need to you have you get a graph is
yes input you need to color the vertices
by two colors or
namely to split the graph into two parts
and you want to maximize the number of
edges that see two different colors
namely that cross the cut so basically
you need to cut the vertices into two
parts and maximizing how many edges go
inside the cut
so unlike three coloring you need to cut
there into three parts when you need to
cut in on
only two parts it's easy to decide
if you can cut a hundred percent of the
edges or not because this is just
whether or not the graph is a vapor that
graph okay so it's actually polynomial
time to decide
to colorability but max cut is not a
polynomial time
uh optimization problem because if
you're getting a graph that is not a
bipartite graph
and you need to maximize the number of
cut edges
in that case uh
we don't know it's actually it's np hard
to do it
and the best known approximation
algorithm is the celebrated gomez
williamson semi-definite
program and the government williamson
algorithm so let me
go back here the government williamson
algorithm
so max that
the gw algorithm
uh shows that if
the value of the of the graph
is at least one minus epsilon meaning
when i say value of the graph in this
case i just mean the graph has a cut
that cuts almost all the edges one minus
epsilon of the edges
okay then their algorithm
the value of the algorithm or the
fraction of edges that they manage to
cut is one minus
square root of epsilon okay so it's a
very
very good algorithm but still there's a
difference between epsilon and square
root epsilon
okay squared epsilon is bigger so the
algorithm is cutting fewer edges
okay so this is the algorithm and
you might wonder whether or not this is
tight maybe there's no algorithm that
does better
and indeed in a a very important
paper a code kindle
muscle and i
[Music]
showed that actually the unique games
conjecture i haven't described what the
indie games are and i agree now
uh if this conjecture is true and it's
talking about the kind of level cover
then it implies that the gw algorithm
is is the best possible
in other words it implies that a
max cut is hard
with a gap of 1 minus root
epsilon and one minus epsilon okay so
this gap is exactly the correct gap
this is of course assuming that the
unique gains conjecture
okay so i should stay here in the games
conjecture
this was a conjecture made by subash ko
just a couple of years before that in
maybe 2003 or two
and this paper i don't know if it was 04
or i don't remember
something um and this was
uh a very big surprise so
in this paper by the way this was a
super influential paper
they didn't quite manage to prove this
reduction they needed something called
the majority stabilized
and so they formulated this as a
conjecture and very
quickly afterwards in a famous paper by
monster or donald knowledge kevitz
that introduced the invariance principle
this was proven so all this diana will
describe the
on monday i believe um
i just wanted one to highlight that
maxcat is kind of a very basic csp
because
it talks about a constraint between two
variables that's as small as possible
and they're boolean variables so it's
kind of the smallest possible
constraint it's very basic and so you
would expect to
be able to analyze how hard it is
and until today we don't know whether or
not this is true
if we don't want to assume the unique
games conjecture so let me say
what what is
[Music]
our unique games
it's the same as a label cover
except that
[Music]
the fuv are one to one
okay so a unique game is uh let me where
did we have
so we had here uh label cover instance
here i defined label cover and a unique
gauge level cover
is a level cover where in addition you
know that these functions fuv from la to
lv
are one to one when you hear it you
don't know if you what does it mean is
it making the problem easier or harder
so it's making the problem easier
because the cons the
the constraints are from a more limited
class
and uh it turns out that if you assume
this
that this kind of label cover has a gap
between zero and one
like we already know for the more
general so
assuming we believe the parallel
repetition theorem we know that label
cover
has a gap between epsilon and one for
any epsilon
the unique gas conjecture says oh you
know if you assume a gap between epsilon
and one minus epsilon
when the constraints are one to one uh
this is a very
good assumption for me and i can prove
for example that max cut
i can prove that the max cut is
the the semi-definite program algorithm
of gomes williamson is tight
okay so sorry about this detour but the
reason
i want to talk about this is because
now this leads me to talk about
the strong parallel repetition
okay so kkmo showed basically a
reduction from unique games
to max cut now at that point you can say
unique games
is kind of a new construct i don't know
about it whereas maxstart is a much more
well studied problem and i know that
it's hard to to beat the gw algorithm
so it would be much more convincing if
you can prove a two-way
reduction can you prove that
if max cuts can
the gap of one minus epsilon and one
minus root epsilon
suppose i assume that this gap is tight
does this imply the unique gains
conjecture
so you really what you're asking is
whether this direction is also true
can i reduce gap max that back to
unique things and that's a very natural
thing to do
moreover there's a very very natural
reduction to do it
it's just parallel repetition okay so
uh so very natural
can we show hardness
of one minuscule deficit on one minus
epsilon max cut
implies hardness
of the epsilon one or let me call it
delta one minus delta
unique gains
this is just uh the unique games
conjecture this is what it says
okay and how will we do it we can just
take a max cut
instance notice that the max cut itself
is a unique game because uh
what are the constraints here you the
constraint are between
two adjacent vertices this vertex has
value
on one side of the cut and the other
vertex should have the opposite value
okay so there's only two values zero and
one so if this guy is zero this one
needs to be one
and vice versa so the constraint is one
to one
and when you take a one-to-one
constraint
and you do parallel repetition on it you
remain a one-to-one constraint so if you
parallel repeat
and you need games uh sorry a maxcut
instance the times
you will still get a unique game so
also
plus parallel repetition
is a very natural
candidate reduction
because parallel repetition of maxcut is
a unique
okay so what do we need we need
to show that if we had if the value
was of the graph or
the max cut is 1 minus epsilon
i know already that the value of the
repeated instance is at least 1 minus
epsilon to the power d
this is just because i will take the
product strategy so
i can always get this value of 1 minus
epsilon to the d
however if i was in a knowing stance and
my value was less than 1 minus root
epsilon
then what kind of theorem do i need to
prove i need to show that the value of g
to the d
is less than well it would be nice if i
could prove 1 minus root epsilon
to the d or even
with some constant okay let me ignore
the constant
this would be would
be wonderful
right because why would this be so
wonderful first of all
um before i say what it would be not
wonderful
we don't know this what we know is that
you need to take this
and raise it to the power 2. right this
is what i told you that the
holland's 10 and r approved it used to
be 32
they moved it down to 2. but of course
if it's two
then you have here one minus epsilon to
the d and here one minus epsilon to the
d
it's useless okay so what you really
need is to get rid of the two once you
get rid of the two
then you you you can choose d
just by choosing d to be somewhere
let's say much smaller than one over
epsilon but
much bigger than one over root epsilon
okay if it's in this range then
this guy would go to almost one
it's still near one and this guy would
go to almost zero
okay and great you have a gap between
almost one and almost zero this is what
the indie games conjecture is telling us
so this is why people really cared about
getting rid of the two to get a
reduction from max cut back to
unique games
okay so um
this was a studied by feige kindler and
o'donnell
this was their starting point and if i
get kingly
actually i don't remember the year sorry
about this
maybe eight i don't know
um but they said okay let's not
talk about all all games let's only talk
about
unique games all i need to do is
parallel repetition
with they wanted to prove oh maybe let
me call it
so this this is the so-called
strong parallel
repetition conjecture
this is what i called wonderful okay so
the conjecture is that
this inequality holds without the two
okay
this is the conjecture that you take a
game of value one minus epsilon
sorry one minus root epsilon and when
you raise it to the power d
the value just raises to the power d
maybe with some constants
okay so they wanted to prove the strong
parallel repetition conjecture
or check if it's true or not and they
said okay we only need to prove it
for unique games we only need to prove
it actually for
max cut type of games where the alphabet
is boolean
and actually let's focus on a specific
game so
focus on a very special case
called the odd cycle game
so what is the odd cycle it's a graph
right with
an odd number of vertices
and and it's not bipartite although it's
like almost bipartite right you can do
a plus minus plus minus plus and so
there's one edge that's kind of ruining
the bipartiteness for you
and as the size of the cycle grows
there's still only one edge that's
problematic
okay so this is the old cycle game and
if you think of it as a cycle on
m vertices let's call it cm then the
value
of cm is is
is roughly 1 minus 1 over m okay
you can kind of cut the vertices in a
way that
okay only one edge is not happy okay
and the question is okay when i take
this specific
this specific graph and i look at the
parallel repetition of this specific
graph
do i get is it true that when i take
this
cm and i raise it to the power d
is it true that i get 1 minus 1 over m
to the power d
this is my the question that the fko
asked
now there is some issue here that i
neglected to tell you which is when you
move from max cut to a label cover
because level cover has a viper type
description
but max cut on a bipartite graph doesn't
make sense
so you need to move to the double cover
of the graph and the way to do it is
that
to describe the odd cycle game so what
is exactly the odd cycle game
it's the following thing i'll tell it to
you in the dramatized version so
there is a graph everyone is looking at
it it's a cycle the referee with
probability half
for free with probability half
chooses an edge uv
sends you to alice
and v to bob and with probability half
the referee chooses just one vertex u
and sends it to both the alice and bob
okay they don't know what happened and
when he sends the same vertice to both
guys he wants
the answer to be the same when he sends
vertices on an
edge to the players he wants the answers
to be different
so this is like are you still seeing me
or
did something bad happen it's okay all
right
so um this is the odd cycle game exactly
so it's like a it's like a double cover
of the graph
it's not important so let's not dwell on
it
uh okay and and the question is whether
the value of this game
goes down like uh
ah it seems that something is happening
what happens
um
okay so my computer i guess is still
functioning but the la the ipad
is disconnected
okay while it's disconnecting i'll tell
it to you without an ipad okay
so okay so they studied this question
about the odd cycle and how you
okay
now it's a good time for a hot spot
okay this looks a bit better
[Music]
share content screen
start
okay we're back right
yeah okay sorry about that guys so um
okay so okay so they tried to study this
and um it turns out that this question
is related to a question about
foam okay foam like soap bubbles that
make
foam related
to
foam in r to the d
in other words it's related to the
following question okay what
is the list area the least
the surface area
of a shape
that tiles
r to the d by shifts of
z to the d
okay so this question turns out that
people
have studied it and it goes under this
buzzword of foam
and um
the surface area here notice that
because you are tiling hard to the d
so maybe the best way to think about it
if i change here to
so imagine this is r to the 2
and i need to put some shape around
every point
for example i can put the square that if
i shift it like this i'm tiling the
entire space
right so square actually works very well
or you know in more generality this kind
of shape the cube
tiles r to the d very nicely but the
surface area here
is roughly d the surface area of this
cube and what is the surface area
of the smallest the kind of and of
course if you're tiling you need
your volume to be one because you're
trying the entire space with this kind
of shift
so when you're tiling and your volume is
one your surface area can certainly not
be smaller than the smallest
geometrical shape whose surf whose
volume is one so the
the shape is of course at least square
root of d
this is how the sphere behaves
okay and this is how the cube
behaves okay it's clear that it's the
right in every direction you need to
play
this in this part so it's one two three
the directions
okay so you need to behave like the cube
to tile the space and your surface area
is going to be at least square root d
but what is the right answer is there
like a crazy shape that actually looks
like a sphere but still tiles
are to the d so this turned out to be an
open question people didn't know the
answer to
the best thing that was known in the
time that this question was uh
discovered by fko
was some kind of shape that's better
than the cube for two dimensions
it's slightly squished and then you just
tensorize it
and it turns out that uh this question
is exactly related to
um to the uh the value of this odd cycle
game so what is the relation
so notice that if you tie r to the d by
shift of z to the d really your shape
the shape naturally lives
in r to the d divided by z to the d
which is nothing other than the taurus
so
you know when d equals two we usually
draw it like this it's like a doughnut
right
this is the two dimensional for us and
we're talking about the d dimension
okay now with a context switch
going back to the odd cycle game
i want to try to explain how objective
game is related to this thing
so what is their relationship
what are the what is the graph
underlying the odd cycle game
so the one-shot game with probability
half the
referee chose an edge and send both
endpoints to the player and
where to have a vertex and send both
them to a player
so i'm asking myself if alice got
queries questions you went up to ud and
bob got questions v1 up to vt
what do i know about the relationship
between these guys okay
so i'm saying you either u ui can be
equal vi
this is something that happens half the
time
or ui equals vi
plus or minus one mod
m so let's now think of kind of when
we name the vertices by numbers from
zero to n minus one modulus
that's just convenient
okay so all in all the vector u
is connected by an edge to the vector v
if and only if
if i look at them in l infinity
their distance is at most one in every
coordinate the distance is either zero
or one
so this is the kind of the graph that
describes what's going on here
okay and if you like to think
topologically you have a
cycle that's the odd cycle game in one
dimension and then you multiply it by
another one now you get the taurus and
you multiply by another one
so if you're used to these things it's
not hard to convince yourself that
the graph is also just the taurus it's
nothing other than the torus
so the graph
underline
this game is the taurus
okay so now at least we had the word
taurus appear twice
once in r to the d divided by z to the d
and once here is the graph so really
it's not that taurus it's a
discretization of the torus
it's discretized
all right so now here's an observation
if you look at this discretization of
the torx
and you look at the part of the of this
graph that has no
non-trivial loops so non-trivial loops
in the in the torus
are exactly the kind of loops here
seeing the doughnut that go around
here or that go around here these are
non-trivial from
topological point of view and you know
this is a
very well-studied area and you can
define it through homotopic whether it's
homotopic to
to a point or not so this kind of loop
going here is trivial
but the one goes around here or here is
not triggered
so if you take an area in the tour in
the d-dimensional tourists
you start kind of growing a shape inside
the stores
and in this shape there are no
non-trivial
loops then you can convince yourself
that inside this shape you can actually
give a strategy to the
players that satisfy all of the edges
inside this ship
because the only problems that kind of
how does the referee detect a problem
when
you try to go along a cycle you do plus
minus plus minus plus minus plus minus
when you close the loop oops you see
that there is a problem in
and there's a bad edge but as long as
you don't close the loop and you avoid
closing the loop you can actually
kind of grow this strategy nicely so
this is kind of
an important observation in
any shape oops
oh i'm running out of time sorry okay
can i take another five minutes
sorry okay any shape with no
a non-trivial without
non trivial loops
and has a strategy has
a has a strategy
without bad edges
bad meaning unhappy edges
okay so if we manage to find a very
large shape
then the only edges that kind of might
be bad and i need to count them
and count them out when i'm calculating
my probability of success
are the edges that go from the shape
outside not exactly the surface area
okay so really what's going on here is
that the size
of the surface area
is exactly the fraction
of rejecting edges
so uh if you look at the paper
if you think about it for a few minutes
uh this is easy to understand
maybe it's not easy in a talk but it's
really a beautiful connection and
uh there's nothing hidden here you think
about it and you'll see this
so really what's going on here is that
if you find
a tiling of art of the d with small
surface area
then inside the shape of the tile you
can you can grow this say strategy
and the only problems the only places
where the strategy will fail is in the
surface area
so what fko showed or proved is that
if there is a phone
a small surface area then a
strong parallel repetition is false but
if
you can prove that all form all all the
ways to tie the space
uh with a shape like this must behave
like a cube
then strong parallel repetition is true
and then you get a reduction from max
cuts to your new games which would be
really nice
okay so that's what they showed and this
kind of motivated
further people further looking at this
and then has proved
uh actually parallel strong parallel
repetition is
false so one minus epsilon squared the
two
there is actually necessary
is necessary
so the bound of the one minus epsilon
squared to the d is actually tight
this is what the improved and actually
how did he show it
he looked at the odd cycle game this
specific game and he showed that for
this game it's not true
that the best strategy is is one minus
epsilon to the d
one minus here epsilon is one one over m
so we said that the value of a single
game is one over one minus one over m
if you raise it to the power d if strong
correlation were true
the value should be this 1 minus 1 over
m
raised to the power of d now ron found a
much better
strategy okay whose value is 1
minus 1 over m squared to the d
okay so we found this strategy later on
uh in a paper by barack
legend and obama i think i named them
all uh
kind of understood this uh construction
of
us in a more generalized way and they
showed really what's playing the key
role here is the semi-definite
programming relaxation of the game in
any unique game
in the odd cycle game is a unique game
in any unique game there is a very
natural and semi-definite
program that is a relaxation of this
game
the value of this program is bigger or
equal to the value of the game
and the way this goes is that each each
variable
each each player instead of giving back
an answer it gives back a vector
okay maybe donna will go into it or
maybe not probably
no time for all of these things but
if you look at the semi-definite sdp
value the semi-different programming
value
this is the value that the parallel
repetition captures so
uh really the odd cycle game the value
is is exactly this one minus
one over m squared this is the sdp value
of the odd cycle game and so this is the
correct value of the parallel repetition
and so strong power position is false
and you do not get
this kind of counter example so just to
finish my talk just to say
okay so the repetition part is false
but what did we learn about phones so in
another work
by uh kindly
vignelson and rao they actually managed
to take this construction of raz and use
it to construct
a tiling of r to the d with surface area
square root d so it's some kind of
strange
shape that on one hand it tiles r to the
d perfectly by
shifts of z to the d and on the other
hand its surface area is like the sphere
it's only square root of d
of course with constants i don't know
the constant and i think actually
nogalon and boss cloudtag
worked on this and got very nice
constants i don't remember there was
some follow-up work
on this okay so i'm over time and
uh so i'll stop here
okay well thanks very much for the talk
and i think there is uh
one question left that hasn't been
answered but but i don't understand what
it says
which part was natural
so i don't know if you understand what
that means but uh
i probably talked about the reduction
from max cut to unique games to be
natural when i said that it's oh new
yorker is talking to us
when i said that it's a natural
reduction to do a tensorization to move
from max cut to immediate games
okay i don't know but if anyone has any
further questions or if whoever asked
that question
would like to clarify and follow up
okay can i ask you a different question
believe that um so if you want to
construct tilings with
you know nice properties my i mean i've
never thought about it but
the thing that i would try to do is i
just draw a bunch of random vectors
and uh iid and i would construct the
uh lattice from that and i would use the
tiling
generated by that lattice does this not
have this nice surface area property
and this is usually the type of examples
that give you
very very nice properties really
wouldn't the surface area i see
i have never thought about these
questions so i don't know
unfortunately maybe someone in the
audience knows more than me
um sorry no
thanks
actually uh a big open question in this
area
which your construction doesn't really
solve but
is that the construction of the coming
from ross's example and so on they're
all randomized
like selecting random vectors and so on
uh we don't know of a deterministic
shape
as far as i know
there are many examples of that right i
mean we we also don't know of a
deterministic
graph that has a clique of logarithmic
size or maximal clique of logarithmic
science oh
of course i mean this is a very big
big issue yeah let's hear one more
one more example okay so someone asked
why was
sensorization a natural oh okay i guess
that's arguable to me
what is a reduction reaction you take
some object you do something to it you
get another object
so one of the most basic things to do is
to tensorize
what can you do really you can do some
local replacement you can tensorize
what else can you do i don't know
are there examples where it's useful to
consider multiple round games
uh sure in many cryptographic settings
uh when you have more rounds the
[Music]
you have much more power the referee has
much more power so
you can get much better properties
but it doesn't have anything to do with
the hardness of approximation so you're
moving into other
other regimes but i don't know if you
may want more rounds sequentially or
more rounds in parallel
if you mean in parallel sequentially
yeah so sequentially yes
there's a lot of
a lot of crypto situations where you
want to do many rounds
and you get properties that we cannot
dream of when you do only one round
actually why does the referee have more
power rather than the player
because the referee tells the player the
answer
kind of keeps challenging the players
and if they fail he catches them right
so if
after one round they didn't fail and now
you're adding another round
it's just more opportunity for them to
fail
okay the more tests you take the more
probabilities you pay
i don't know but also because the
referee can use the answers from the
previous rounds to try and
get them in the trap yeah
thanks joe yeah so you answer something
in the
first round and the referee still
remembers it right so
kind of i don't know
one one more question that i wanted to
mention is uh
three player palette repetition which
looks naive
like oh it's like two-player if we know
how to analyze this we know how to
analyze that
this is wide open uh to prove
exponential decay
we don't know how to do it there's a
kind of some new work on it very
recently by running justin holmgren
cool oh so this is not a question this
is a
reply to ramon's question but it does
not correspond to a lattice basis
so how do you understand the question
the answer there is a measure called the
signal measure which i don't know
and if you select from that then you do
get the surface area of square root d
i think he's claiming that you don't i
don't know maybe nike you can
i don't think i can meet you daniel
sorry to
daniel's saying something about no we
can mute can't we
i i think uh i do i can power to unmute
but like
this yes
daniel you should be unmuted yeah uh can
you hear me
yes yep yeah no so so there are
different ways of
of generating uh lattices in a way that
you would
call random and uh uh
yeah the the seagull measure is
is uh sort of um
uh how would you do like the yeah it's a
bit complicated to describe there's like
a poor man's version of it which is not
so complicated to describe which i can
do
maybe which is like basically you pick
um a run a random sub lattice of the
integer lattice
uh where you um basically take
all integer uh points that satisfy a
random modular equation modulo p
like um and um
that's like a poor man's version of this
thing and if you look at what are called
the
you know the vornor cells of this
lattice so just all the points that are
closest to the origin
uh than anyone else that induces a
tiling
and that tiling will basically look like
a ball
like the the voronoi cell will look like
a ball
uh so it will have surface area square
root d is what you're saying yes
but if you pick the lattice to have like
uh you know a basis of uh you know
gaussian vectors or something then the
basis is kind of orthogonal
uh which um you know we'll give you
uh like a vorn ourselves looks more like
a cube than like a ball
well it depends on how many of these you
pick of course if you expect an
exponential number
yeah if but if you pick more than n
vectors then then then you won't have
like a basis
uh that's right okay yes i'm with you
right
but will you be tiling with respect to
your own lattice or with respect to z to
the d
yeah so you tau with respect to your own
lattice yeah that's why this question is
very different
than uh yeah it's it's it's quite it's
quite different than
than tiling with respect to zn
so the answer is that that
the the gist of my idea works but my
description of how you generate a random
lattice is not a useful one
yes yes but i think some of the tiling
with respect to zeran
uh is yeah
is kind of a different question in some
sense it's like
if you were to change this if you were
to take the tiling induced by the
voronoi cell
uh and then you could apply the linear
transformation or a linear
transformation that turns the lattice
into zn
uh that would destroy the surface area
completely um
so so so somehow the question
specifically for zn
is is is of a different nature
i'm glad someone was in the audience who
could give us some more insight here
okay cool so if there aren't no more
further questions then i'll just remind
everyone that there's a discord server
that you can continue to discuss
i think this room just stays open right
until the next talk
maybe yeah okay